c'est un sujet effectivement qui est
sensible mais je pense quand même je
rejoins l'analyse qui a été faite par
jean marc four que emmanuel macron a
raison d'y aller parce que alors il ya
le côté tactique politicienne
effectivement on sait que sympathisant
elle est en particulier sont très
sensibles à ce sujet ils ont quand même
une de leur priorité numéro un
mais même quand on élargit le la focale
et qu'on regarde l'ensemble des français
c'est un sujet sur lesquels les français
ont des attentes un peu fort alors c'est
un peu un sujet tabou on soit trop
s'exprimer mais par exemple je peux vous
dire que plus d'un français sur deux
estime qu'en france il ya trop
d'immigrés aujourd'hui et seulement 14 %
d'entre eux pensent que l'immigration a
un impact positif par rapport à ce qu
elle ce qu'elle offre au pays donc je
pense qu'à des attentes assez forte des
français
et s'il arrive à jouer cette espèce
d'équilibré de gens montrent un
humanisme et fermeté ça peut être plutôt
payant pour lui pris au gouvernement